اسرائيل واعلنت نشر وحده القوات الخاصه
يمام بشكل دائم في القدس وهي واحده من 4
وحدات تتبع لشرطه حرس الحدود تعمل في
القدس ومناطق الدفه الغربيه واغلب عناصرها
من جنود الجيش الاحتلال السابقين الذين
خدموا في محادثه القتال الخاصه تنقسم
الوحده لعده فرق ومدن انتفاضه الثانيه
تركز عملها على الاغتيالات وتصفيه النشطاء
وبشكل عام تتشكل المنظومه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه من عدد من الاجهزه ابرزها
الجيش اهم مؤسسه واكبر من الله جهاز
الشباب ويعمل تحت اشراف رئيس الوزراء يهدف
للقضاء على ما يسميه الارهاب الداخلي
وتامين المناطق الحيويه في اسرائيل ويعمل
بما تقسيمه المناطقيه ويعتبر القطاع
العربي واكبرها شرطه اسرائيل وهي جهاز
يهتم بالامن الداخلي والحفاظ على النظام
العام في اسرائيل
اليها في البدايه
حرس الحدود وحده قتاليه تابعه مباشره
لشرطه اسرائيل لمنع تسلل اليها ويتدخل حرس
الحدود وقت الحاجه ووفقا لتوجيهات وزير
الشرطه لصد مظاهرات او قمع مسكره
واعتصامات
[موسيقى]